King Leopold II ruled over Belgium from 1865
to 1909.
Today, the memory of his reign still lives
on, and he is glorified with golden statues
of his likeness in every major city in Belgium.
In history classes, each generation is taught
that he was a humanitarian who brought Christianity
and the wonders of civilization to The Congo
Free State.
However, the truth has been kept away from
the Belgian people.
The reality is that King Leopold II is responsible
for the murder and mutilation of 10 million
Congolese people.
This just may be the biggest cover-up in European
history.
Early and Personal Life
Leopold II was born in 1835 to King Leopold
I and Louise-Marie of Orleans.
They were the very first royal family of Belgium,
because the country was just 5 years old.
For thousands of years, that territory had
been conquered by nearby Netherlands, France,
Germany, and Luxembourg.
They were a newly independent country that
had yet to form a unique national identity.
Leopold II had two younger siblings called
Phillipe and Charlotte.
Their family life was dysfunctional, to say
the least.
Soon after Charlotte’s birth, in 1844, King
Leopold I met a 16-year old girl named Arcadie
Claret.
He was 54 years old at the time, but that
didn’t stop him from having an affair with
a teenage girl.
Claret would go on to become a Baroness, and
her sons, Georg and Arthur, were made into
Barons.
There were rumors that Leopold I had several
other affairs, so the exact number of half-siblings
Leopold II has out there is actually unknown.
Queen Louise-Marie was understandably miserable
in her marriage, and she chose to let out
her anger on her children.
She would make fun of young Leopold II’s
large nose that he inherited from his father.
She told her son that his face was “disfigured’,
and that he had the beak of a bird.
In 1853, when he was 18 years old, Leopold
II had an arranged marriage with Marie Henriette
of Austria.
Since he had never actually seen what a loving
marriage looks like, the teen couple was incredibly
awkward around one another.
Someone in the Belgian royal court had commented
that seeing them together was like watching
a “nun and a stable boy”.
People thought that this was so hilariously
accurate, the phrase was repeated amongst
everyone who knew them.
Apparently, his parents cared so little about
Leopold, that they never even bothered to
tell him about the birds and the bees.
Leopold’s aunt, Queen Victoria of England,
had a great marriage with her husband Albert,
and she apparently gave her nephew a lot of
sex advice...
Which was probably exactly as awkward as you
might imagine.
Leopold II and Marie Henriette eventually
figured it out, because they had two daughters
together.
When Leopold I died in 1865, Leopold II ascended
the throne as the new King of Belgium.
Since his personal life was so dysfunctional,
it’s really no surprise that his happiness
and satisfaction came from attaining material
things.
According to William II, the ruler of Germany,
he was together watching a parade with Leopold
II in Berlin, when he commented, “There
is really nothing left for us kings except
money.”
Building His Fortune
Before he died, King Leopold II’s father
made 50 attempts to conquer a colony for Belgium,
but he had always failed.
It was clear to him that the power other countries
like England, France, Germany, and the United
States had was thanks to colonization.
Leopold I believed that without colonizing
an African nation, they would never be considered
one of the larger world powers.
Leopold II picked up where his father left
off, but he did not want to conquer a nation
on behalf of Belgium.
He planned to make an entire country his personal
property, instead.
This way, he could have complete control,
and have direct access to the profits.
He knew that if he was honest about his greedy
intentions, none of the other major powers
would agree to let him colonize an entire
country all for himself.
So, he told everyone that it was his mission
to spread Christianity in The Congo.
He wanted to convert and civilize those poor,
Godless souls.
In 1884, he met with 14 other European nations
at The Berlin Conference.
He pitched his idea for colonizing the Congo,
and claimed that he wanted to spend his own
fortune to bring missionaries to Africa out
of the goodness of his own heart.
He also promised that the rest of Europe could
freely explore and trade from his country
as they pleased.
The Congo was known for being incredibly dangerous,
and difficult to colonize.
The rainforest and savannah are filled with
gorillas, lions, leopards, and wolves.
The Congo River has man-eating crocodiles
and hippopotamus, and insects carry deadly
diseases.
In general, it was a very wild place, and
not many Europeans wanted to live there.
If Leopold II really wanted to take on the
challenge, the other world powers didn’t
see anything wrong with it.
A Welsh explorer and journalist named Henry
Morton Stanley already had years of experience
in Africa.
He was sent on projects by several different
newspapers in the United Kingdom, and he became
an expert on the continent.
Through his writing, he tried to convince
Queen Victoria that despite all of the difficulty,
he believed it would be worthwhile to colonize
the Congo.
His suggestions never made any impact, until
King Leopold II found Stanley’s work.
In 1879, the king sent him on a mission to
colonize the Congo.
Henry Morton Stanley used parlor tricks to
convince the African tribal chiefs that white
men were invincible.
He used a battery-powered contraption to make
his grip so strong, Congolese men almost collapsed
from a mere handshake.
Stanley claimed that white men could rip a
tree out of the ground with his bare hands.
He held a magnifying glass in the sunlight
and used its reflection to light his cigar,
claiming that white men had power over the
sun.
Finally, he handed a gun to a native man.
He instructed him to step back several yards,
and try to shoot him.
Stanley had taken the gunpowder and bullet
out beforehand, of course, and when the young
man pulled the trigger, Stanley would double
over dramatically, only to take his shoe off
and shake the bullet onto the ground.
He claimed that white men were spirits who
could not be killed, no matter how hard they
tried, and that a bullet would pass right
through them.
This was enough to terrify the chiefs into
signing his contract that declared King Leopold
II as the new owner of The Congo.
Of course, the Congolese people had no idea
what the contract actually said, but it served
as a legal document in the eyes of European
people.
Leopold wanted to keep up the illusion that
he was going to do good in the country, so
he went as far as to name it “The Congo
Free State”.
Henry Morton Stanley published a book about
his journey through Africa called Through
the Dark Continent.
He was able to go on a lecture tour around
London, and he was even knighted in the year
1899.
Colonization and Exploitation
Leopold II truly was paying for all of the
startup expenses to colonize The Congo out
of his own pocket.
He appointed governor generals to manage the
various territories of the country.
Leopold’s men eventually discovered that
the rainforest had a plentiful supply of rubber
trees.
This was like stumbling across a gold mine.
At the time, there was a huge demand for natural
rubber in order to make tires, but there was
a very small supply.
The only problem, of course, was finding a
way to pay for manual labor.
Leopold II ordered his men to enslave the
Congolese people.
Each of the governor generals had their own
tactic to achieve this.
Usually, they set a village on fire, so that
there was nowhere for anyone to hide.
They would shoot and capture the women of
the village, and tell the men that if they
did not each bring back 15kg of rubber by
the end of the day, they would kill their
wives and daughters.
The Congo Free State was anything but free.
King Leopold II believed that all of these
people were his personal slaves, and he could
do whatever he wanted with them.
King Leopold personally handed out bonuses
to the commanders if they could produce more
rubber, by any means necessary.
Leopold began to grow his own private army
in the Congo called The Force Publique.
When his men were destroying a village, they
would pick out the tallest and strongest-looking
young men to recruit them as soldiers.
These captured soldiers were instructed to
systematically kill anyone who disobeyed the
orders of the governor generals.
They were told that they were not allowed
to waste any ammunition, and that they must
kill a man with a single bullet.
They were required to bring back one severed
hand for every bullet fired.
If they did not, they would be killed by their
general.
This lead to the soldiers cutting the hands
off of people that were still alive, whenever
they wasted ammunition.
Meanwhile, in Europe, people had no idea what
was actually going on.
Word got around that King Leopold II needed
more soldiers to help with his “Christian
mission” to colonize The Congo.
Hundreds of young men from Belgium, Italy,
Norway, Sweden, and Denmark all signed up
to join The Force Publique.
They were taught that these black natives
were animals, and not fully human like them,
so they shouldn’t feel guilty about killing
them when necessary.
After a while, these men became desensitized
to the killing.
Some of the soldiers would gut people and
pull out their entrails, or slice off a group
of men’s genitalia only to hang them in
a row.
Some of the governor generals wrote letters
to King Leopold II about these scenes, because
they were actually proud of the brutality.
They believed that the worse they treated
the Congolese people, the harder they worked.
Over time, King Leopold’s men managed to
enslave the entire population of the Congo.
Even though he had promised that the rest
of the world could visit The Congo whenever
they wanted, King Leopold II became very nervous
when he learned that Arabian merchants were
coming to gather some rubber for themselves.
He did not want to lose his monopoly over
the industry, so he declared that they needed
to go to war with these so-called “Arab
slave traders”, in order to “free” his
Congolese people.
This sparked the two year Congo-Arab War.
In 1895, an English merchant named Charles
Stokes was on a mission for the Germans to
travel to the Congo to purchase rubber.
He was hung by The Force Republique without
receiving a trial.
Germany and Britain were outraged that he
was killed without ever committing any crime.
Leopold was forced to pay substantial fines
to both governments for violating the treaty,
and the incident was called The Stokes Affair.
However, paying this fine was just a drop
in the bucket.
King Leopold II made a profit of 220 million
francs, which would be worth more than $1
billion today.
Exposing The Truth of Leopold’s Lies
Leopold II hired a team of propaganda writers
to publish books and articles about what a
great job he was doing.
None of these writers had ever actually traveled
to The Congo Free State, but they were happy
to glorify their king’s Christian mission.
However, journalists from Great Britain and
The United States were beginning to travel
to The Congo Free State and report what they
saw.
In the year 1890, an American Civil War veteran
named George Washington Williams visited The
Congo Free State, and he was horrified.
He wrote an open letter to King Leopold II,
recounting the horrors he witnessed while
visiting the country.
The King never replied.
A man named Edmund Dene Morel worked as a
clerk at a shipping firm in Liverpool, England.
Belgian ships would come and go delivering
rubber to Liverpool from The Congo.
Murel knew that it wouldn’t be possible
for Belgium to produce such a high volume
of rubber, unless they were using slave labor.
He began investigating, and when he discovered
the horrors about what was actually happening,
he wrote several anonymous articles for a
British newspaper called The Speaker, exposing
the truth about what he saw.
He wrote that this was “the greatest crime
that has ever been committed in the history
of the world.”
In 1901, the shipping company offered Morel
a job to manage the shipments of rubber to
and from The Congo.
They were willing to pay him a huge salary
in exchange for his silence.
He turned it down, and became a full-time
journalist instead.
He became so passionate about the cause, that
he began publishing his own newspaper called
The West African Mail with any new information
he found.
In 1906, he published a book called Red Rubber.
Another journalist named Roger Casement was
sent to interview people of the Congo to get
their testimonies about the human rights abuses
in the country.
He realized that it was crucial to convincing
the white Christian missionaries to come forward
with their stories, because they had been
there from the beginning, and they could prove
that King Leopold II was aware of the atrocities.
After Roger Casement’s report was published,
King Leopold II knew that if he did not respond
with his own inquiry, this would be the end
of him.
He sent his own International Commission to
the Congo, in hopes that he could bribe them.
He thought that he could pay them off to publish
whatever he wanted them to say.
This totally backfired.
A Christian missionary named John Harris had
been living in The Congo Free State for years.
He and his wife devoted their lives to helping
the Congolese people.
When King Leopold’s International Commission
showed up, John Harris was ready for him.
He gathered a group of Congolese people who
testified to the death, torture, mutilation,
rape, and enslavement that they suffered at
the hands of King Leopold’s men.
His wife, Alice Harris, was a photographer,
and she was able to present them with photographic
evidence of the horrors they had seen.
When the International Commission returned
to Belgium, they published a 50-page report
on all of the human rights abuses they had
found in The Congo, and submitted it to King
Leopold II.
Once he realized that he could no longer get
away with his lies, Leopold ordered all of
the Congo Free State records to be burned,
so that there would be no evidence of his
crimes.
In 1908, The Congo became a Belgian colony,
but they didn’t seize it from the King.
Instead, they paid him 50 million francs for
the purchase.
He died just one year later, in 1909.
A Shocking Legacy
Once the Belgian government visited The Congo,
they found far more profitable resources than
just rubber.
There were diamonds, gold, and ivory that
could be sold for massive profits.
The government ended slavery, and employed
the Congolese people to work for wages, instead.
Very soon after, Belgium became extremely
wealthy.
The city of Brussels now has some of the most
breathtaking architecture in the world, complete
with golden statues of King Leopold II, all
because of the money he brought in from The
Congo.
But the Belgian government had to make a decision-
What do they tell the public?
Leopold II had lied to his people for so long,
and they looked up to him like a father figure
who brought glory to the country.
Not only would the citizens be disappointed,
but it would make Belgium look terrible to
the outside world.
Their nation was still less than 100 years
old at the time.
England and the United States had already
outlawed slavery in the 1800’s, so their
short history, their king had already managed
to take steps backwards in humanitarian progress.
The Belgian government chose to allow their
people to continue believing the lie that
King Leopold II had built for himself.
They taught their children that there never
was any slavery in The Congo Free State, and
that everything King Leopold II did was wonderful.
This lie was retold generation after generation,
to the point where it became their new truth,
and part of their cultural identity.
Before his death, in 1897, Leopold II created
a human zoo at his summer estate.
He built a model African village and captured
267 Congolese people to live there.
Belgian people showed up to gawk at them,
throwing peanuts and bananas over the fence,
as if they were monkeys.
They were forced to stay outdoors in these
village in all kinds of weather.
Seven of those people died of influenza and
pneumonia.
After he died, the king’s estate became
The Royal Museum of Central Africa, and it
continued to glorify Leopold II’s achievements
in colonization.
Decades after his death, in 1958, the government
of Belgium even went so far as to replicate
his human zoo at the Brussels World Fair,
putting Congolese people on display like animals
once again.
Nearly every western nation has some history
of slavery and genocide, but in most Belgian
classes, they will never hear the truth about
King Leopold II.
They will say that slavery never happened
in The Congo.
Since the records were destroyed, we will
never know just how many people Leopold was
responsible for killing.
Some estimate that it is roughly 4 million,
while others believe it is as high as 10 million.
Somewhere between 70 to 90% of the total population
was wiped out.
In the age of the internet, it has become
much more difficult for Belgium to ignore
the reality of what happened.
In 2018, the curators of the Royal Museum
of Central Africa finally decided to change
the exhibits to honor the lives lost by the
native Congolese people.
However, Congolese people who visited the
exhibit said that it’s still not enough,
and that as long as the story is told from
the perspective of a white Belgian person,
the country will never show the full truth
about the monstrous deeds
of
King Leopold II.